it's a tr rehab
just kind of introducing you all to my
new hobby that i have here
besides my little sports cars that i
like tinkering with i
find myself back to the gardening thing
we started late on everything of course
that was due to the
covic crisis maybe june july we decided
to put something in the ground
uh started off with some tomatoes three
plants
then we went to some string beans that
did very well
we had plenty of cucumbers what i did
learn about the cucumbers is worms love
them just as much as we do
for every 10 that i picked i probably
was able to keep three
but this year we're better prepared for
that because uh the experience was uh
worth every bit of it
these were the first two beds that that
we did
i planted these late also everything i
did last year was just
late but a lot of people told me that
during winter
uh greens wouldn't work well my buddy
mike reynolds
told me something a little different so
i decided to try it
and this is what i have now and this is
january 2nd 2021
these have been covered up for probably
the last two weeks or so because we had
some really hard coal
got down to 20 degrees but look at these
babies
talk about proud now what i am going do
uh maybe let these get up to about six
to eight inches
and then i'll thin them out hopefully i
can get
uh maybe 12 in this bed here this bed
here was my wife's idea
not really what i wanted to do but you
know how it is when the
wifey says this is what she wants she
don't really care what you think about
it
she just wanted to do it i'm glad she
did that
because as with pretty much everything
that i do
it's a trial and error thing look at
what we have here
see those little babies this is a winter
crop
best thing that i'm told you can grow in
the wintertime
spinach eat them babies
but uh at last count i think i had
close to 60 plants i'ma thin those out
when they get
probably about six inches high or maybe
just
let them stay where they are it's my
first time ever doing this
i used to watch my grandfather do it
when we were growing up so
in theory i've seen it done before
didn't really know what he was doing
but um sometimes just putting your eye
on something and watching it and then
later on in life
it tends to come back around my broccoli
here
i just let them stay out now i did have
to go and pluck a few leaves off because
that cold did
a little damage to them
this is my first year and all of these
were grown from seeds
this one i don't know this must be a
child of another mother because i think
it has
uh there's one
there's two there's three
and there's four like i said i did have
to uh
take a couple of leaves off because the
coal
did a little damage to them but for the
most part they made it
i may cover these up the next time we
get down into the 20s
because i thought they could handle it
and this is some spearmint
i got a bucket of that and these two
here is where i grew my tomatoes last
year
this raised bed here was the last one
that i did
basically some roof tin put me a little
bevel on it
and then a little light stain beds are
lined with some plastic
so the soil is actually not touching
the metal this is absolutely my favorite
this is what i want my entire garden to
look like
because when the springtime hits all of
this is green
back here but uh i want this thing to
look
really pretty i dedicate this to my wife
because had she not
going out and actually bought the
material i would have never started this
this is something that we talked about
for years
but we never got to it she went up to
lowe's or home depot and came back with
some wood and some bricks and said come
and do the garden
i just thank you for tuning in and
watching me as i grow
because uh not only am i growing plants
but i'm hopefully growing in spirit
growing in knowledge and growing healthy
that's what this is all about
give a man a fish he could feed his
family for a day
teach a man to fish he could feed his
family for a lifetime
tiara rehab